Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History, the podcast that needs no vaccine passport to roam freely across the boundaries and the centuries. And today we're heading back in time three and a half thousand years. We're going to be starting by talking about a boy who took the throne in Egypt when he was about eight years old and proceeded to marry his half-sister. Or did he? So much of his life is shrouded in mystery.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是一个不需要疫苗护照就能在各个国界和世纪间自由漫步的播客节目。今天我们要将时间倒回三千五百年。我们要从一个大约八岁时登上埃及王位并进而迎娶了自己同父异母姐姐的男孩说起。或者他真的这么做了吗？他的一生有太多谜团。
Our subject, or at least the subject that we're going to kick off with, is of course Tutankhamen, who's captivated our imaginations since Howard Carter discovered his tomb 99 years ago. But of course, there's more to Tutankhamen than the boy himself or the tomb. Tom Holland is with me. Tom, this is a subject I know you know loads about and has fascinated you since you were a kid. Let's start with just Tutankhamen, because he's the one pharaoh that everybody has heard of.
我们今天的主题，或者至少是我们切入的主题，当然是图坦卡蒙。自从霍华德·卡特在99年前发现他的陵墓以来，他就一直吸引着我们的想象力。但当然，关于图坦卡蒙，除了这个男孩本身或他的陵墓之外，还有更多内容。汤姆·霍兰和我在一起。汤姆，我知道这是一个你非常了解的课题，而且你从小就对它着迷。让我们先从图坦卡蒙开始，因为他是每个人都听说过的唯一一个法老。
What is it about him, do you think, that has seized their imagination? Yeah, he's the most famous pharaoh by miles. And yet, when he was alive he he didn't reign for very long he was a very obscure pharaoh and the reason of course that he is famous is that he is the pharaoh whose um tomb full of treasure survived the depredations of robbers and so when we think about the glory of the pharaohs this kind of golden realm we we think of toot and carmen because there we get a glimpse of the incredible wealth the sophistication the uh the beauty of that incredible civilization but on top of that i think there are two further reasons why toot and carmen is so famous and why his story is so haunting the first
你认为究竟是什么让他如此吸引人们的想象力？是的，他是迄今为止最著名的法老。然而，在他活着的时候，他并没有统治很长时间，他是一个非常不知名的法老。当然，他之所以出名，是因为他是那个……陵墓里装满宝藏、躲过盗墓贼洗劫的法老。所以当我们想到法老们的辉煌、这种黄金国度时，我们会想到图坦卡蒙，因为我们在那里得以一窥那个不可思议的文明惊人的财富、精致和美丽。除此之外，我认为图坦卡蒙之所以如此著名、他的故事之所以如此挥之不去，还有另外两个原因。第一个
is the story of how it was found so the process by which howard carter came to uncover the tomb you know it goes back years and decades and it's kind of the last gasp howard carter is about to have his funding cut and then he discovers this stairway and they peel away the dust and they get down there's a door and it's intact and you've got the story of the curse and everything so that's brilliant but i think even more than that what makes it fascinating from the historical point of view is that obscure though tutankhamen is he is an actor in what is perhaps the most remarkable extraordinary enigmatic period in egyptian history which is associated with the
是关于它是如何被发现的故事，也就是霍华德·卡特发掘陵墓的过程。你知道，这可以追溯到几年甚至几十年以前，这可以说是最后的挣扎。霍华德·卡特的资金即将被切断，然后他发现了这个楼梯，他们剥开尘土，走下去，发现了一扇门，而且它是完好无损的。你还有关于诅咒的故事等等，所以这太精彩了。但我认为，从历史的角度来看，更吸引人的是，尽管图坦卡蒙名不见经传，但他却是埃及历史上最卓越、最非凡、最神秘的时期中的一个参与者。这个时期与
the guy who was probably his father um a pharaoh called akhenaten who was married to um a queen whose face is almost as famous as tutankhamen's nefertiti's and akhenaten is famous as the pharaoh who essentially initiates an entirely exceptional process of revolution that was so shocking and upsetting to the Egyptians that they buried his name in oblivion and Tutankhamen's name was buried as well and that's basically why his tomb survived because he was forgotten. Okay don't tell us what Akhenaten did because for listeners who don't know that can be our big reveal later on when we get into the Akhenaten story. Because I agree with you, I think the Akhenaten story is one of the, I think it's without any question, one of the single most interesting stories in all world history. And I'm talking about thousands of years.
这个很可能是他父亲的家伙有关——一个名叫埃赫纳吞的法老，他娶了一位王后，其面容几乎和图坦卡蒙一样出名，那就是娜芙蒂蒂。埃赫纳吞作为法老而闻名，他本质上发起了一场极其独特的革命进程，这对埃及人来说是如此令人震惊和不安，以至于他们将他的名字埋葬在遗忘之中，图坦卡蒙的名字也被埋葬了。这基本上就是他的陵墓得以幸存的原因，因为他被遗忘了。好了，先别告诉我们埃赫纳吞做了什么，因为对于不知道的听众来说，这可以是我们稍后深入探讨埃赫纳吞故事时的重磅揭秘。因为我同意你的看法，我认为埃赫纳吞的故事是毫无疑问的、整个人类历史上最有趣的故事之一。我说的是几千年的跨度。
But let's just focus for a second about Howard Carter. Now, Howard Carter's story, it's interesting, isn't it it because it's one that all children learn certainly all british children um and what is it about it do you think that you know he's working for lord carnarvon i mean i can remember this from the kids i read as a from the books i read as a kid you know he's working for lord carnarvon and there's the story about the curse and the dog barking in Cairo or whatever. That's right. Or dying and all that sort of thing. So how much, tell us, I mean, you all know much more about this than me.
但让我们先花点时间关注一下霍华德·卡特。现在，霍华德·卡特的故事很有趣，不是吗？因为这是所有孩子都会了解的故事，当然所有英国孩子都会学到。你认为是什么让这个故事……你知道，他为卡那封勋爵工作——我的意思是我从我小时候读的书里还能记起这些，你知道，他为卡那封勋爵工作，还有关于诅咒的故事，以及开罗有狗在叫之类的传闻。没错。或者狗死掉之类的各种事情。所以，请告诉我们，我的意思是，你们对这个的了解比我多得多。
Tell us some of the sort of background to all this. So Carter was, he was a professional archaeologist? No, no, he wasn't. And this is part of the romance of it, is that he was an illustrator. And he went out as quite a young man to Egypt. And and there he met um the brilliantly named flinders petrie um who was an archaeologist and flinders petrie was working at a site called amarna which is about halfway between luxor and cairo and don't spoil the reveal by telling us about i won't but um so this is a part of what howard carter immediately gets gripped by and and this is a buried city that hasn't been excavated before
给我们讲讲这一切的一些背景吧。所以卡特他是一位职业考古学家吗？不，不，他不是。这就是它的浪漫色彩的一部分，他其实是一位插画家。他很年轻的时候就去了埃及。并在那里遇到了名字非常奇特的弗林德斯·皮特里，他是一位考古学家。弗林德斯·皮特里当时正在一个叫阿马尔纳（Amarna）的遗址工作，该遗址大约位于卢克索和开罗之间。别剧透，先别告诉我们关于——我不会的——所以这是霍华德·卡特立刻被吸引住的一部分，这是一个以前没有被发掘过的埋藏之城。
so it's kind of virgin territory and carter is doing the illustrations for this and he just get completely gets the bug he stays on he um he ends up being employed the french at the time are running the antiquity service in e Egypt for kind of complicated colonial reasons. And Carter is is employed by this colonial French agency basically as a superintendent of antiquities until he gets into a punch up with some French tourists who are essentially being incredibly rude to an Egyptian. And Carter takes the Egyptian side and gets dismissed for this. So the sense that- It's a good story.
所以这有点像处女地，卡特当时正在为这个做插画，他彻底迷上了。他留了下来，他……最后受雇于法国人，当时出于某种复杂的殖民原因，法国人正在管理埃及的文物部门。卡特基本上被这个殖民时期的法国机构雇为文物监督员，直到他和一些对埃及人极其粗鲁的法国游客发生了一场斗殴。卡特站在了埃及人一边，因此被解雇了。所以这种感觉——这是一个好故事。
Yeah, so Carter is kind of on the side of the angels, but he's a temperamental, difficult man. And from that point on, he stays out in Egypt and he basically hires himself out to visiting grandees, billionaires, Americans, British,ish whoever who essentially coming to egypt and um they get give they buy kind of the right to excavate certain areas and they employ carter and there's a guy called theodore davies who's an american millionaire who comes to the
是的，所以卡特有点像是站在正义的一边，但他是个性格暴躁、难以相处的人。从那时起，他留在埃及，基本上把自己的服务出借给来访的显贵、亿万富翁、美国人、英国人，无论什么人，他们基本上来到埃及，然后他们获得并购买了在某些地区发掘的权利，并雇用了卡特。有个叫西奧多·戴维斯（Theodore Davis）的美国百万富翁来到了
valley of the kings and carter helps him out um theodore Davies discovers all kinds of fascinating tombs. One in particular, KV 55, so Valley of the Kings 55, is an enigmatic tomb that I'm sure will come to with a mummy in it. It's unclear whether it's male or female. seems to that seems to have been some process of desecration going on no one's quite sure about it um davis uh discovers this in 1912 he then thinks that um or is it 1907 can't remember anyway we'll have to check um he then uh reckons that that the whole of the valley of the kings has every tomb has been discovered but carter because there is a link between tutankhamen and amarna that will come to he's particularly aware of the fact that tutankhamen's tomb has not been found that this is the one tomb that might be discovered and so when lord carnarvon comes out who is is there for his health you know the egyptian climate is seen as being very healthy he comes out um he employs
帝王谷，卡特帮助了他。西奥多·戴维斯发现了各种各样的迷人陵墓。其中有一个特别的墓，KV 55，也就是帝王谷55号，这是一个神秘的陵墓，我确信我们后面会谈到，里面有一具木乃伊。目前还不清楚它是男是女。似乎……似乎发生过某种亵渎的过程，没有人完全确定。戴维斯在1912年发现了这个。他随后认为……或者说是1907年？记不清了。总之，我们得核对一下。他随后……认为帝王谷的所有陵墓都已经被发现了。但卡特因为图坦卡蒙和阿马尔纳之间有某种我们将要谈到的联系，他特别清楚图坦卡蒙的陵墓还没有被找到，这可能是唯一尚未被发现的陵墓。所以当为了健康来到埃及的卡那封勋爵到来时（你知道，埃及的气候被认为非常健康），他来到这里，雇用了
carter carter says look let's go for toot and carmen and they dig and they dig and they dig and they don't find it and years go by and 1922 comes around and carnarvon says to carter look this is going to be the last season uh and carter goes okay and that's the jeopardy and then carter you know carter discovers it and he has to wait for lord carnarvon to come over um they go down secretly without telling anyone and carter kind of opens up the the the door and carnarvon's behind him and says you know can you see anything and carter says you know there's this pause and then he says wonderful i can see things i can see wonderful things and the romance of it is so incredible it's and it's it's it's the kind of the paradigm of what people imagine an archaeologist's
卡特。卡特说：“听着，我们去找图坦卡蒙吧。”他们挖了又挖，挖了又挖，却没有找到。几年过去了，到了1922年，卡那封对卡特说：“听着，这将是最后一个发掘季了。”卡特说：“好吧。”这就是危机所在。然后卡特，你知道，卡特发现了它，他不得不等待卡那封勋爵赶来。他们没有告诉任何人，秘密地走了下去。卡特打开了门，卡那封在他身后说：“你能看到什么吗？”卡特停顿了一下，然后说：“太奇妙了，我看到了东西，我看到了奇妙的东西。”这种浪漫色彩是如此不可思议，它是……它是人们想象中考古学家
life is is like but it never is isn't it i mean that's the tragedy it never is no other archaeologist ever has that no no i mean no no archaeologist has ever has has ever had that kind of howard carter experience and then you throw into the mix the story of the curse which is that uh the story goes there's this guy who's a rival of of carter's called arthur vagal who was um employed by the daily mail dominic so very much the lowest of the low uh to cover the uh to cover the excavation and carter and canarvan has given exclusive rights to the Times. So Ogle is there. He's resentful of Carter for this great find.
生活模样的典范，但它从来都不是真的，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是悲剧所在，它从来都不是真的。没有哪个考古学家会有这种经历，没有，我是说，从来没有哪个考古学家有过那种霍华德·卡特式的经历。然后你把诅咒的故事也加进来，这个故事是这样的：有一个卡特的竞争对手叫亚瑟·韦加尔（Arthur Weigall），他当时被多米尼克口中的《每日邮报》雇佣——这绝对是下三滥的做法——来报道发掘工作。而卡特和卡那封把独家报道权给了《泰晤士报》。所以韦加尔也在那里。他因为这个重大发现而对卡特心怀怨恨。
He's crossed... They were owned by the same group in those days, in the 1920s. That's the irony. He's crossed that the Times has got the exclusive. And so he sees Carnarvon going in, and he's supposed to have said, if he goes in in that mood, I give him, you know, six weeks. And then the story goes that he nicks himself shaving,
他跨越了……在那个年代，也就是20世纪20年代，他们属于同一家集团。这就是讽刺之处。他气恼《泰晤士报》获得了独家报道权。所以他看到卡那封走进去，据说他说过：“如果他带着那种心情进去，我给他（能活）六周时间。”然后故事说，他在刮胡子时把自己割伤了，
it gets infected. And this nick supposedly exactly models a nick that will be found on the face of toot and carmen you're right that the moment he dies um there's a power cut across cairo and his dog back in uh back in high clear which is that which is uh downton abbey um howls and this is the story of uh of of the curse but i mean carter obviously the person who proves that the curse isn't real is is carter because he does not die of it um how disappointing yeah it is okay so there's also i mean obviously with susan carmen a huge element of the appeal um again before we get into that and arts and stuff the huge element of the appeal is that he's a child is that he's a boy pharaoh
伤口感染了。而这个伤口据说完美地对应了将在图坦卡蒙脸上发现的一个伤口。你说得对，就在他死的那一刻，整个开罗发生了一次大停电，他在海克利尔（Highclere，也就是《唐顿 Abbey》的取景地）的狗发出了号叫。这就是诅咒的故事。但我的意思是，卡特显然是那个证明诅咒并非真实存在的人，因为他并没有死于诅咒。多么令人失望啊。是的，确实如此。好吧，那么这里还有——显然，对于图坦卡蒙来说，吸引力的一个巨大组成部分，再次强调，在我们深入探讨艺术之类的事情之前，吸引力的一个巨大要素是他是个孩子，他是个少年法老。
and we always have this fascination he's kind of late teens isn't he but he becomes what he's 8 or 9 when he becomes pharaoh I suppose yeah he kind of dies when he's about 17 I think so in other words he's the same age as a lot of children when they first read about Tutankhamen
我们总是对这一点充满迷恋。他大概是十几岁吧？但他成为法老时大概八九岁，我想是的。他死的时候大概十七岁左右，我想是的。换句话说，他和许多第一次读到图坦卡蒙故事的孩子们年龄相仿。
and it's that sort of sense of doomed youth I think that people it's that sort of sense of doomed youth, I think, that people... It's the sort of... The contrast between the doomed youth and then the gilded but ossified splendour of the remains that I think we often like about the Tutankhamen story. And of course, that's why we go to museums
正是这种命中注定的青春感，我认为人们……正是这种命中注定却又早逝的青春感，我认为人们……这种青春的早逝与遗迹镀金却又僵化的辉煌之间的对比，我想正是我们通常喜欢图坦卡蒙故事的地方。当然，这也是为什么我们会去博物馆
and we enjoy seeing all the artefacts. But the intellectual appeal of the story, and this is where we come to the big reveal is his it's really his father who's this fellow akhenaten who must be one of the most fascinating and mysterious characters in all human history and i know you are passionate about this so why don't you tell us the you know give us an outline for people who don't know anything about ancient egypt give us the story okay so akhenaten is the son of a pharaoh called amonotep which means um basically amon is pleased and amon amon rey is the by by the time that this is, so this is kind of 1370, 1360 BC. It's in the 18th dynasty of Egypt. And Egypt is...
并喜欢欣赏所有文物的原因。但这个故事的 intellectual（知识层面/精神层面）吸引力——这就是我们迎来重大揭秘的地方——实际上是他的父亲，也就是那个名叫埃赫纳吞的家伙。他必定是整个人类历史上最迷人、最神秘的人物之一。我知道你对此充满热情，所以你为什么不给我们讲讲……为那些对古埃及一无所知的人勾勒一个轮廓，给我们讲讲这个故事。好吧，所以埃赫纳吞是一个叫阿蒙霍特普的法老的儿子，这个名字的意思基本上是“阿蒙是满意的”，而阿蒙——阿蒙·拉在此时已经……所以这是公元前1370年或1360年左右。这是埃及第十八王朝。埃及是……
So Egypt's been going for like... Yeah, it's been going for... More than a thousand years. Yes, yes, yes. It's an incredibly ancient civilization. And under the 18th dynasty, it's incredibly powerful. Egypt had been occupied by Asiatic invaders called Hyksos and they had been expelled by the ancestor of the 18th dynasty and not only had the Asiatics been expelled but the pharaohs had then expanded northwards and
所以埃及已经存在了……是的，它已经存在了……超过一千年了。是的，是的，是的。这是一个极其古老的文明。在第十八王朝时期，它极其强大。埃及曾被被称为“喜克索斯人”的亚洲入侵者占领，他们被第十八王朝的先祖驱逐了。不仅亚洲人被驱逐了，而且法老们随后向北扩张，
established a kind of loose empire reaching right the way up into Syria. And Amenhotep III is kind of like the Louis XIV of ancient Egypt. He is the sun king. Everything about him is golden. He's wealthy. He ruled for a very long time. Huge statues. So if you go to the British Museum, there's a huge kind of head of him with this kind of enigmatic rather self-satisfied smile as well you might be if you were aminotep the third um and the priests of amun are basically um you know they're they're massive they're a kind of massive power in the land they uh they run these huge vast temples um and aminotep the third's son who will succeed him and become Amunotep IV is actually committed to another god and a few years into his reign he signals this by changing
建立了一个一直延伸到叙利亚的松散帝国。阿蒙霍特普三世有点像是古埃及的太阳王路易十四。他是一代太阳王。关于他的一切都是金色的。他很富有。他统治了很长时间。有巨大的雕塑。所以如果你去大英博物馆，那里有一个他巨大的头像，带着一种神秘的、颇为自命不凡的微笑——如果你是阿蒙霍特普三世，你也会如此。阿蒙神的祭司们基本上是……你知道的，他们势力庞大，是这片土地上的一股巨大力量。他们管理着这些庞大宏伟的庙宇。而阿蒙霍特普三世的儿子、将继承他的王位并成为阿蒙霍特普四世的人，实际上致力于另一个神。在他统治的几年后，他通过改变
his name from Amunotep, Amun is pleased, to Akhenaten which means basically you do stuff for the for the Aten and the Aten is the disc of the sun and Akhenaten's devotion to the Aten is such that he basically launches a kind of an attack against Amun. He closes the temples to Amun. He moves to this place that now is called Amarna, where Howard Carter and Flinders Petrie were digging. And which at the time was called, Akhenaten calls it Akhetaten, the horizon of the Aten. And Akhenaten builds an entire city there
他的名字来表明这一点：从阿蒙霍特普（意为阿蒙是满意的）改为埃赫纳吞（Akhenaten），意思是“为阿吞神效力”。而阿吞神是太阳神盘。埃赫纳吞对阿吞神的虔诚如此之深，以至于他基本上发起了对阿蒙神的攻击。他关闭了阿蒙神庙。他搬到了现在被称为阿马尔纳（Amarna）的地方，也就是霍华德·卡特和弗林德斯·皮特里挖掘的地方。当时这个地方被称为——埃赫纳吞称之为“阿赫塔顿”（Akhetaten），意为“阿吞的地平线”。埃赫纳吞在那里建造了一座完整的城市，
devoted to the worship of this god, Aten and Akhenaten builds an entire city there devoted to the worship of this this god Aten and the thing that's astonishing about this and something that has kind of echoed through you know Freud writes about it all kinds of people write about it is that essentially Akhenaten is a monotheist and he's a monotheist who is reacting against the vast array of gods that the Egyptians have always taken for granted and he writes these kind of hymns we assume that Akhenaten writes and we don't absolutely know this for sure but he's conventionally the great hymn to the Aten and he hails the Aten as sole god without another beside him. And in the context of Egyptian assumptions about the universe, about the role played by the gods,
致力于崇拜这个神，阿吞神。埃赫纳吞在那里建造了一座完整的城市，致力于崇拜这个神——阿吞神。而最让人惊奇的是，某些在历史上引起共鸣的事情（比如弗洛伊德写过它，各种各样的人都写过它），本质上是埃赫纳吞是一位一神论者。他是一位一神论者，他反对埃及人一直视为理所当然的众多神灵。他写了这些赞美诗——我们假设埃赫纳吞写了这些，我们虽然不能百分之百确定，但传统上认为他是《阿吞神赞美诗》的作者——他将阿吞神尊为独一无二、旁无所傍的神。在古埃及人对宇宙的假设以及神灵所扮演角色的背景下，
this is so revolutionary that Egypt is left kind of stunned by it. And when Akhenaten dies, the process of kind of rolling this revolution back begins immediately because Tutankhamen is initially called Tutankhaten. So Tutankhaten is the living image of the Aten. Tutankhamen, he becomes a living image of Amun. And Tutankhamen becomes the kind of figurehead
这是如此具有革命性，以至于埃及被它震惊得目瞪口呆。当埃赫纳吞死后，扭转这场革命的进程立即开始了。因为图坦卡蒙最初被称为“图坦卡吞”（Tutankhaten），意思是“阿吞的活生生的形象”。而图坦卡蒙后来成为了“阿蒙的活生生的形象”。图坦卡蒙成为了某种反革命的傀儡，
of a counter-revolution, which then he dies. He gets succeeded probably by his great uncle, a guy called Ai. Then Ai dies and he gets succeeded in turn by a guy called Horemheb, who is a kind of general. And it's under Horemheb that the entire memory of Akhenaten and his revolution basically gets flattened. And Akhenaten, Tutankhamen, Ai, they all get written out of the king lists. So that, you know, a few centuries on, although there are very interesting kind of echoes of the horror of this that are buried, Akhenaten's own name and Tutankhamen's name get completely forgotten. And no one has any idea that they existed until Flinders Petrie arrives at Amarna and starts excavating and finding,
随后他死了。很可能是他的叔祖父、一个名叫艾（Ai）的人继承了他的王位。然后艾死了，接着由一个名叫霍伦海布（Horemheb）的将军继承了王位。正是在霍伦海布统治期间，关于埃赫纳吞及其革命的所有记忆基本上被彻底抹去。埃赫纳吞、图坦卡蒙、艾，他们都被从国王名单中除名了。以至于几个世纪后，尽管有一些关于这段恐怖历史的非常有趣的余音被埋藏着，但埃赫纳吞本人的名字和图坦卡蒙的名字还是被彻底遗忘了。没有人知道他们的存在，直到弗林德斯·皮特里抵达阿马尔纳开始发掘并清理、挖掘出所有这些东西。本质上，这里的悖论是，正是这一点让图坦卡蒙得以幸存。
digging up all this stuff. And basically, the paradox is that that is what enables Tutankhamen to survive. So there's so much to unpack here. Maybe we'll get to the purely religious stuff, which I know you're fascinated by, and the influence of Akhenaten and the way that people have tried to understand, you you know is he the father of all our monotheistic
所以这里有太多内容需要剖析了。也许我们会探讨纯粹的宗教问题（我知道你对此很着迷）、埃赫纳吞的影响，以及人们试图理解的方式——你知道，他是我们所有一神教的之父吗？
religions and all the rest of it but just looking back on this as a sort of historian of the 20th century what's really striking to me about it is you have this guy who come you know he's had a a very domineering father who was the great pharaoh, who was kind of, I think, deified in his own lifetime, Amenhotep III. Then Akhenaten comes in. He says there's a new belief system, a new cultural form. So there's a new kind of art.
以及其他种种。但仅从20世纪历史学家的角度回顾这一点，真正让我感到震惊的是：你有这样一个家伙，他……你知道的，他有一个非常专横的父亲，那就是伟大的法老、甚至在生前就被神化的阿蒙霍特普三世。然后埃赫纳吞登基了。他说有一种新的信仰体系，一种新的文化形式。所以有一种新型的艺术。
If you see the images of him, I mean, they're really weird, elongated kind of faces. And, you know, so the art has changed. He has an entirely new city in the desert, a new site that's away from the old capitals. The temples have changed, so they're open-air temples. Everybody can be seen. You're being surveyed the whole time by the sun,
如果你看到他的雕像，我的意思是，它们真的是那种奇怪的、拉长的脸庞。你知道的，所以艺术改变了。他在沙漠中建立了一座全新城市，一个远离旧都的新地点。神庙变了，变成了露天神庙。每个人都能被看到。你一直在被太阳监视，
but also by his police and by his kind of security forces and stuff. I mean, he feels a disturbingly modern figure i mean he's somebody that if you put him alongside you know pol pot i mean it sounds like a ludicrous comparison but again somebody who wanted to completely remake society in the service of an ideology akhenaten you know you can paint him as an ancestor for modern totalitarians. Or do you think I'm being unfair? Well, I think you are being a bit unfair because I think one of the fascinations of this period is also the frustrations. There's just enough material to sense that there's something incredibly important and fascinating going on here. But there's not quite enough material to have a definite sense
同时也受到他的警察和安保部队等的监视。我的意思是，他给人的感觉是一个令人不安的现代人物。我的意思是，他是一个如果你把他放在……你知道的，波尔布特旁边——听起来这可能是一个荒谬的类比，但同样是一个想为了意识形态而彻底重塑社会的人——埃赫纳吞，你知道的，你可以把他描绘成现代极权主义者的先驱。还是你觉得我不公平？嗯，我认为你确实有点不公平，因为我认为这个时期令人着迷的地方之一也是它的令人沮丧之处。这里有刚刚好的材料，让你感觉到这里正在发生一些极其重要和迷人的事情。但材料又不够充分，无法让你确切地了解
of what was actually going on. And we can't ultimately know for sure, you know, really what the revolution involved. We can't know for sure who, you know, even whether Tutankhamen really was Akhenaten's son. All these kind of relationships are up for grabs. And therefore the temptation is always, when you look at someone like Akhenaten,
当时究竟发生了什么。我们最终无法确切知道这场革命到底涉及什么。我们无法确切知道，甚至连图坦卡蒙是否真的是埃赫纳吞的儿子都无法确定。所有这些关系都充满争议。因此，当你审视像埃赫纳吞这样的人时，诱惑总是
is to back project your own assumptions. So to begin with, in the kind of high Victorian period, the kind of late Victorian period, people associated Akhenaten with a kind of seen as an effete lover of peace who hadn't had the the cojones to um to stand up and fight for for the egyptian empire and what added to that is that partly because of his statues yeah well it's partly because it's so weird and androgynous in his yeah it's partly because of the but partly because of the hymn to the aton where he's he he it's it's kind of quite a universalist hymn so there's the sense of kind of egypt was being radically different from the lands beyond has gone um and you know this is kind of very kind of radically distinctive approach but it's also as you say yes so that the amarna art
将你自己的假设投射到过去。首先，在维多利亚时代晚期，人们将埃赫纳吞与一种……被视为一个软弱的和平爱好者联系在一起，认为他没有足够的勇气站出来为埃及帝国战斗。而加剧这种印象的原因是，部分原因是因为他的雕像——是的，部分原因是因为它在样貌上如此怪异和雌雄同体——部分原因是因为《阿吞神赞美诗》，在诗中他……这是一种相当普世主义的赞美诗，所以那种“埃及与境外土地截然不同”的感觉已经消失了，你知道，这是一种非常激进而独特的视角。但正如你所说，阿马尔纳艺术
is incredibly odd and akhenaten is portrayed with kind of a huge great cranium, often kind of hint of breasts, a woman's hips and buttocks, and then very kind of thin spindly legs. And when it's on engravings, these look odd, but when you get them as statues and huge statues that were kind of raised at Karnak and which then got buried beneath the rubble and got extracted by 20th century excavations. And they're, I think, the strangest works of art that I've ever seen. They kind of dominate. They're really unsettling, aren't they?
也极其古老和怪异。埃赫纳吞被描绘成拥有巨大的头颅、常常带有乳房的暗示、女性的臀部和屁股，以及非常纤细细长的双腿。当它们出现在雕刻上时，这些看起来就很奇怪，但当你把它们做成雕像，以及那些在卡纳克竖起、随后被埋在瓦砾下并在20世纪发掘中被出土的巨大雕像时，它们是我见过的最奇怪的艺术品。它们占据主导地位。它们真的让人感到不安，不是吗？
So they're in the Cairo Museum and to stand beneath them and look up at them, you feel there's a sense of power there. And so people have wondered, well, what the's a sense of power there and so people have wondered well what the hell was going on here and so they people have said well maybe he had kind of a variety of medical conditions and this is what it's portraying but actually i don't think it's anything to do with that so again and again through through pharaonic history you look at a pharaoh and you think oh you know there's one who's got huge ears he looks like prince charles
所以它们在开罗博物馆里，站在它们下方抬头仰望，你会感觉到那里有一种力量感。因此人们会想：“好吧，那里的力量感是怎么回事？”人们会说：“好吧，也许他有某种各种各样的医疗状况，这正是雕像所描绘的。”但实际上，我认为这与此毫无关系。因此，在法老历史中一次又一次地，你看一个法老，你会想：“哦，你看那个耳朵好大，他看起来像查尔斯王子，也许他就是长那样？”然后，不，那是因为耳朵代表着倾听。关于阿吞神的事情是，男性和女性都包含在他体内。而埃赫纳吞将自己表现为阿吞神的儿子——在凡人中只有他这么做，实际上他的妻子娜芙蒂蒂也这么做，但他们是一个三位一体。
maybe that's what he looked like and then no, it's because the ears are all listening. And the thing about the Aten is that both male and female are contained within him. And Akhenaten is presenting himself as the son of the Aten, who alone among mortals, actually Nefertiti, his wife, does as well. But they're a kind of trinity. And so just as nefertiti is portrayed in quite a masculine sense and in due course after akhenaten's death seems to have ruled as a male pharaoh so akhenaten in his statues is given kind of feminine characteristics um and this is entirely to do with the kind of the the theological sense of what the aton is um and i think that that's the focus of it. It's not, I don't think that by the 30s, by the 40s, into the 50s, people are kind of very prone to see totalitarian dictators
所以，正如娜芙蒂蒂被赋予了相当男性化的形象，并且在埃赫纳吞死后似乎以男性法老的身份进行统治一样，埃赫纳吞在他的雕像中也被赋予了某种女性特征。这完全是为了契合阿吞神在神学意义上的本质。我认为这就是重点所在。我不认为在30年代、40年代直到50年代，人们倾向于在这个人物身上看到极权主义独裁者。再次说明，我认为这并不完全正确。因为埃赫纳吞更像是——他更接近穆罕默德，我认为。
in this figure. Again, I don't think that's quite right. Because Akhenaten is kind of, he's more of, he's closer to Muhammad, I think. he's someone who who for radical reasons is trying to close down the temples of other you know of amman in particular and to give no role whatsoever to other gods and he is prepared to go as far as he can to encourage people to have a stake in that but you know but he's this is kind of bronze age. He doesn't have the apparatus of a totalitarian state to enforce that. And the measurement of that is that when he dies, the whole thing basically,
他是一个出于激进原因试图关闭其他神庙（特别是阿蒙神庙）并剥夺其他神灵任何角色的权力的人。他准备竭尽全力鼓励人们投入到这项事业中，但是，你知道，这也是青铜时代。他并没有极权国家的机器来强制推行这一点。衡量这一点的标准是，当他死去时，整个事情基本上就像
like a stack of cards falls down. Okay, well, let's hope no one says that of this podcast. We're about to take a break and we'll come back. And I think Tom will be talking to us about religion. Knowing Tom, we shall find out. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
纸牌屋一样倒塌了。好吧，希望没有人对这个播客说这样的话。我们马上休息一下，一会儿回来。我想汤姆会跟我们聊聊宗教。以我对汤姆的了解，我们一定会知道的。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about, we started talking about Tutankhamun and we've gone a little bit further back and we're talking about his father, Akanaten, who i think
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在谈论——我们一开始谈论的是图坦卡蒙，现在我们把时间推得更久远一点，谈论他的父亲埃赫纳吞。我个人觉得他有趣得多，汤姆。当然还有另一个人物，那就是娜芙蒂蒂。我们都知道娜芙蒂蒂——娜芙蒂蒂甚至在《神秘博士》里出现过，我记得很清楚，这就是历史重要性的衡量标准，不是吗？她去进行了一场名为“太空船上的恐龙”的冒险。
is personally i find much more interesting tom there's another figure of course which is nefertiti now nefertiti we all i mean nefertiti's been in doctor who i well remember there you go that's the measure of historical significance isn't it she went she went on an adventure called dinosaurs on a spaceship dinosaurs and nefertiti it was the greatest program ever made fighting she was she and a victorian explorer were fighting dinosaurs right um so nefertiti we all remember because the bust there's a great bust of nefertiti and it's this fantastic it's a head of her of her head yeah um the other let yes not the other kind of bust um tell us about nefertiti is she more than a head? I mean, is she more important historically?
恐龙和娜芙蒂蒂，这是有史以来最伟大的节目。她和一个维多利亚时代的探险家一起与恐龙战斗。所以，我们都记得娜芙蒂蒂，因为有一个娜芙蒂蒂的半身像，这是一个极棒的头像——是的，她的头部的半身像。另一个……是的，不是那种半身像……给我们讲讲娜芙蒂蒂，她不仅仅是一个头像吧？我的意思是，她在历史上更重要吗？
She is a very significant figure. So the 18th dynasty has two ruling pharaohs who are female. There's Hatshepsut, great pharaoh who, wonderful Mochi temple, sends a voyage to the mysterious land of Punt. And then you have, it nefertiti um her name means um a beautiful lady has come um nobody's intelligible who her parents were probably a though i think who the guy who succeeds tootin carmen um and she is very important in akhenaten's religion.
她是一个非常重要的人物。第十八王朝有两位女性统治法老。哈特谢普苏特是一位伟大的法老，拥有奇妙的摩柯神庙，并向神秘的蓬特土地派出了远航船队。然后你有娜芙蒂蒂，她的名字意思是“美丽的女子已经到来”。没有人能完全弄清她的父母是谁，可能是——尽管我认为可能是那个继承了图坦卡蒙的人。她在埃赫纳吞的宗教中非常重要。
So she's signed up to it. She completely signs up to it. And when you, in the tomb images, you have the disc of the Aten and then you have the rays that come down. At the end of the rays, you have hands. And these hands, they bless Akhenaten and they bless Nefertiti. And Nefertiti, unusually for queens who are standing next to their husbands, is the same size. So this is a kind of reflection of the huge significance that Nefertiti has. Now there was... There were images, Tom, where they're holding hands and stuff.
所以她是这个信仰的拥护者。她完全接受了它。当你在陵墓的图像中看到时，你会有阿吞神的圆盘，然后你会看到光芒照射下来。在光芒的末端，你会看到手。这些手祝福埃赫纳吞，也祝福娜芙蒂蒂。娜芙蒂蒂和那些站在丈夫身边的寻常王后不同，她和丈夫一样高大。这反映了娜芙蒂蒂所具有的巨大重要性。当时还有……
Yeah. They're really extraordinary. Yeah. So the sense of kind of closeness, of connubial closeness is really important. And it was thought that for decades, that after about 12 years of Akhenaten's reign, that Nefertiti vanishes from the record, and that she'd been kind of driven into disgrace. But that's no longer the consensus. And the consensus now is that after Akhenaten dies, Nefertiti takes on a male pharaonic name, and seems to have ruled for several years. And then Tutankhamen succeeds her. So she's a very significant figure, too.
汤姆，还有他们手拉手之类的画像。是的。它们真的非常非凡。是的。所以那种亲密感，夫妻间的亲密感非常重要。几十年来，人们一直认为，在埃赫纳吞统治大约12年后，娜芙蒂蒂从历史记录中消失了，她被赶入了失宠的境地。但这不再是目前的共识。现在的共识是，在埃赫纳吞死后，娜芙蒂蒂采用了男法老的头衔，并且似乎统治了好几年。然后图坦卡蒙才继承了她的王位。所以她也是一个非常重要的人物。
But of course, the reason that she lives in the memory is, as you say, this incredible bust that is in the Berlin Museum that was found in the early 20th century and got taken to Berlin. And the one guy who absolutely adored it, oddly, was Hitler. And Hitler was obsessed by Nefertiti. And Goering at one point was going to return the bust of Nefertiti to the Egyptian government. And Hitler personally stepped in to stop it because his dream was that when he built the great capital of Germania after global triumph,
但当然，她留在人们记忆中的原因，正如你所说，是柏林博物馆里那尊在20世纪初被发现并被带到柏林的不可思议的半身像。奇怪的是，唯一绝对崇拜它的人是希特勒。希特勒对娜芙蒂蒂痴迷不已。戈林一度打算将娜芙蒂蒂的半身像归还给埃及政府，但希特勒亲自出面阻止了，因为他的梦想是，当他在全球胜利后建立伟大的日耳曼尼亚首都时，
he was going to build a massive, great complex of a museum to Egyptology and the bust of Nefertiti was going to be kind of under a dome as the central object for it. So what's all that about because the nazis also were really interested in the the atten story weren't they and the worship of the the i mean they were they found all that absolutely fascinating and was that just because they everybody found it fascinating in the 20th century or was the the way that they can um
他要建造一个庞大宏伟的埃及古物学博物馆综合体，而娜芙蒂蒂的半身像将作为其中的核心展品放置在穹顶之下。这到底是是怎么回事？因为纳粹对阿吞神的故事也非常感兴趣，不是吗？还有对阿吞神的崇拜——我的意思是，他们发现这一切绝对迷人。这仅仅是因为20世纪的每个人都觉得它很迷人，还是因为他们可以……
they can justify uh being enthusiastic about the beauty of Nefertiti is that her name means the beautiful lady has come. So they argue that therefore she wasn't a native Egyptian. They argue that she came of Aryan stock and that this is why she's so beautiful. So she can be enshrined as a kind of icon of Aryan womanhood. And so which is another example of people projecting fantasies onto this onto this subject this is a very nice this is a very nice link um 20th century people projecting fantasies back onto the sort of Akhenaten Nefertiti Tutankhamen period because the most famous person who does this is Sigmund Freud and i think it's his last book moses and monotheism
他们可以为自己对娜芙蒂蒂美貌的热情进行辩解，是因为她的名字意思是“美丽的女子已经到来”。所以他们认为她因此不是本土埃及人。他们认为她拥有雅利安血统，这就是为什么她如此美丽。因此她可以被供奉为雅利安女性气质的某种偶像。这又是人们将幻想投射到这个课题上的另一个例子。这是一个非常好的、非常巧妙的联系——20世纪的人们将幻想投射回埃赫纳吞、娜芙蒂蒂和图坦卡蒙的时期，因为最著名的这样做的人是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。我认为这是他的最后一本书《摩西与一神教》，
where now he has this theory which has i think pretty much been debunked but which has lasted i mean it's created all kinds of conspiracy theories and stuff about akhenaten and judaism so do you want to take us through that because this is really is yeah it's well so freud is freud is is thinking about akhenaten and the relationship to moses because of course akhenaten is a monotheist and moses is the legendary founder of jewish monotheism um and akhenaten um is thinking about this as he's preparing to go into exile he comes to london it's the last as you say the last thing he's right freud you mean thank you yes freud so yeah freud didn't slip there um and very good freud freud is wondering not um basically freud is asking the the question why why do people hate
在这本书中，他提出了一个理论——这个理论我认为已经被彻底揭穿了，但它一直持续了下来——它创造了关于埃赫纳吞和犹太教的各种阴谋论等等。你想带我们了解一下吗？因为这确实是……是的，好吧，所以弗洛伊德正在思考埃赫纳吞与摩西的关系，因为埃赫纳吞是一神论者，而摩西是犹太一神教的传说中的创立者。埃赫纳吞……
the jews why the nazis hate us why are they doing? And he traces it all the way back to what he sees as a kind of moment of historical trauma. And his thesis is that Moses, he points out, is an Egyptian name. So Moses means child. So Rama sees his son of Ra. And he says that the original Moses was an atonist so a follower of Akhenaten who had this kind of elevated pure spiritual monotheism and he after the collapse of Akhenaten's regime he leads the Hebrews out of Egypt and preaches to them this kind of austere and uncompromising monotheism and the the israelites get so fed up with this that they kill him and instead they worship um a midianite god called yahweh and they conflate the identity of the uh the priests that they've killed with the priest
弗洛伊德在准备流亡、来到伦敦时正在思考这个问题，正如你所说，这是他写的最后一本书……谢谢你，是的，弗洛伊德。所以，是的，弗洛伊德在那里没有口误——非常好，弗洛伊德。弗洛伊德在思考……基本上，弗洛伊德在问这个问题：为什么人们讨厌犹太人？为什么纳粹讨厌我们？他们为什么要这样做？他将这一切追溯到他所认为的历史创伤时刻。他的论点是，如他所指出的，摩西是一个埃及名字。所以摩西意味着孩子，就像拉美西斯是拉的儿子一样。他说，最初的摩西是一个阿吞信徒，也就是埃赫纳吞的追随者，他拥有这种高尚、纯粹的精神一神论。在埃赫纳吞政权崩溃后，他领导希伯来人离开埃及，向他们宣讲这种严厉且不妥协的一神论。而以色列人对此感到如此厌烦，以至于他们杀死了他，转而崇拜
of this midianite god who's also called Moses who they also come to call Moses and so Freud says that um that that basically uh the foundations of Judaism are this kind of buried moment of trauma that the Jews have forgotten about that they killed their father if you like um if you can see the appeal of this to Freud that they killed yeah they killed this Atenist father and basically what Freud is doing is back project because the thing about about Akhenaten is that he is reacting against the gods of Egypt he's reacting against his own father though isn't he yes he's reacting against the fun but he's also reacting against against the gods and it's this
一个名叫雅威的米甸神，并且他们将他们杀死的那个祭司的身份与这个米甸神的祭司混为一谈——这个米甸神的祭司也叫摩西，他们后来也开始称他为摩西。因此弗洛伊德说，基本上……犹太教的基础是犹太人已经忘记的这段被掩埋的创伤时刻，他们杀死了他们的父亲，如果你愿意这么看的话——你可以看出这对于弗洛伊德的吸引力——他们杀了……他们杀了这个阿吞信徒父亲。基本上，弗洛伊德所做的是将后来的观念投射回去。因为关于埃赫纳吞的事情是，他是在反抗埃及的神灵，他也是在反抗他自己的父亲，不是吗？是的，他在反抗父亲，但他也反抗神灵，正是这一点
that makes him hated and it's this that makes him kind of identified with disease and why his memory is buried. So essentially, Freud is saying that the origins of what makes the Jews hated by other people is not actually of Jewish origin. It lies with Egypt and it lies with Akhenaten and his revolution. And you're right, people i mean this is a kind of again it's a it's another fantasy but it it it is expressive of the way in which the the relationship of akhenaten to moses and to the tradition of monotheism is something that people kind of remain completely fascinated by and well let's talk about that a bit because that's something that's so crucial to your recent work so in a way we've kind of undersold what a revolutionist was so if you partly because i i think it's hard for people to understand because they think of religion as something that is a kind of optional bolt on to your life you know you're religious or you're not you kind of it's like a hobby um you go to church on a sunday but for the egyptians and indeed for anybody at that time you know religion wasn't an accessory it wasn't part
让他招致仇恨，正是这一点让他被等同于疾病，并导致他的记忆被埋葬。因此，本质上，弗洛伊德是在说，犹太人受人憎恨的根源其实并非源自犹太本身，而是根植于埃及，根植于埃赫纳吞及其革命。你说得对，人们——这又是一种幻想，但它表达了这样一种方式：埃赫纳吞与摩西以及一神教传统的关系，是人们完全着迷的一个事物。那么让我们多谈谈这一点，因为这对于你近期的作品至关重要。所以在某种程度上，我们有点低估了这是一场多么彻底的革命。如果部分原因是因为——我认为人们很难理解，因为他们把宗教视为一种对生活来说可有可无的附加品，你知道的，你信教或者不信，这就像是一种爱好，你周日去教堂。但对于埃及人来说，事实上对那个时期的任何人来说，宗教并不是一种装饰品，它不是生活的一部分，它就是生活。神灵无处不在，它们构成了你的整个文化和想象世界。所以要打破这一点，并说所有那些神灵都是胡说八道，只有一个神，而所有其他神灵以及你想象和文化世界里的其余部分都是谎言或无稽之谈。
of life it was life the gods were around you all the time you're it was your entire cultural and imaginative world so to break with that and to say all those gods are balderdash there's only one god and all the other gods and all the rest of your imaginative and cultural world is a lie or is nonsense. I mean, that's that's a greater break than the coming of communism in Russia in 1917 or anything like that. Completely. I mean, completely devastating because you're erasing the entire mythology that has given meaning to your life and actually particularly to your death so in a sense that's the most radical thing of all is that um for the egyptians normally when you see the sun going through the sky and then it goes down into the underworld and there's a kind of great fight with with with a demon and then it comes back up again and human beings are intimately bound up with this
我的意思是，这比1917年俄国共产主义的到来或任何类似的事情都要彻底得多。完全彻底。我的意思是，这是完全毁灭性的，因为你正在抹去赋予你生活意义、特别是赋予你死亡意义的整个神话。所以在某种程度上，这是最激进的事情：对于埃及人来说，通常当你看到太阳穿过天空，然后它落入地下世界，并与一个恶魔进行一场大战，然后它再次升起，人类与这一切紧密相连。
struggle and as a as a a human you um you don't see you know the gods but you don't see them and then when you die you that's when you see the gods but akhenaten gets rid of all that so he describes the atom going through the sky and then the coming of night and all the kind of mythology for it has gone and so presumably all the mythology about what happens to you when you die has gone as well and essentially um everybody in in um in akhenaten's egypt they can see the sun so they can see the god but they can't know it because the only person who can know it in fact the only two people who can know it are akhenaten and nefertiti so essentially that's must be frightening terrifying completely terrifying and i think that that explains the the kind of the violence of the reaction against what he was talking people
挣扎着，作为一个人类，你嗯，你看不见神灵，直到你死后才能见到神灵。但阿肯那顿摆脱了这一切，他描述阿顿穿过天空，然后夜幕降临，所有那类神话都消失了，所以大概关于你死后会发生什么的所有神话也随之消失了。本质上，阿肯那顿埃及的每个人都能看到太阳，所以他们能看到神，但他们无法真正了解它，因为唯一能了解它的人——实际上只有两个人能了解它——就是阿肯那顿和娜芙蒂蒂。所以这本质上一定是非常可怕、令人恐惧的，我2认为这就解释了人们对他所说的事物的激烈反应。
it was a kind of psychic strain that was it was kind of overwhelming but then it also explains i suppose because it's such a colossal break because it's the first time somebody has said there's only one god not lots of gods but it's also i guess the first time that a single individual a powerful individual has said to you know hundreds of thousands millions of other people what you think is wrong you must now follow my new order you know it's the first time recorded his instance in history of somebody creating a new order which is something that we're now very familiar with and because of that it's left this huge intellectual and cultural afterlife hasn't
这是一种压倒性的精神压力，但这也解释了，我想，因为这是一个如此巨大的决裂，因为这是第一次有人说只有一个神，而不是许多神。但我想这也是第一次有一个个人，一个有权有势的个人，对成千上万、数百万的其他人说，你们的想法是错误的，你们现在必须遵循我的新秩序。你知道，这是历史记载中第一次有人创造一个新秩序，这是我们现在非常熟悉的事情，正因为如此，它留下了巨大的智识和文化后代，不是吗？
it so thomas mann wrote about it in his book joseph and his brothers philip glass has an opera about yes yes and scholars still argue about this don't they there's a fellow who i know you Yes, yes. which is essentially about, it looks at how Freud kind of interprets it, but traces it all the way back, actually all the way back to the Egyptian period. And he argues that the stories that are told in the Ptolemaic period, say the period after Alexander, after Alexander has conquered Egypt, and then into the Roman period, that various stories are told in which trace elements of Akhenaten can just about be distinguished. And essentially there's a story by an Egyptian priest called Menethos, who is living in the reign of the second of the Ptolemies the the royal Macedonian royal dynasty and he
所以托马斯·曼在他的书《约瑟及其兄弟》中写过它，菲利普·格拉斯有一部关于它的歌剧，是的，是的，学者们仍在争论这个，对吧？我认识的一个家伙——是的，是的。这本质上是关于，它审视了弗洛伊德如何解读它，但一直追溯，实际上一直追溯到埃及时期。他认为在托勒密时期讲述的故事，比如说亚历山大之后的时期，在亚历山大征服埃及之后，然后进入罗马时期，讲述了各种各样的故事，其中阿肯那顿的痕迹勉强可以被辨认出来。本质上，有一个由一位名叫曼涅托的埃及祭司讲的故事，他生活在第二个托勒密统治时期，即马其顿皇家王朝，他
Minitho describes how um there is uh a priest who leads lepers out into the desert and the priest is is from Heliopolis so the the the city of Ra so there's a kind of identification with the sun there and he leads people who have a sick with leprosy and with plague out into the desert and he gives them um kind of the the strange teachings in which everything is upended so there are no gods that all the multiplicity of gods have dissolved um there is only one god. All the dietary rules that the Egyptians hold are turned on their heads. And this priest then comes back and he conquers Egypt. He has the Hyksos, the Asiatics behind him. They rule and then the pharaohs come and they kick them out and throw them out for good.
曼涅托描述了，嗯，有一个祭司带领麻风病人进入沙漠，这个祭司来自赫利奥波利斯，也就是拉的城市，所以那里有一种对太阳的认同，他带领那些患有麻风病和瘟疫的人进入沙漠，并给他们一种奇怪的教义，其中一切都被颠倒了：没有神，所有众多的神都解体了，只有一个神。埃及人信奉的所有饮食规则都被颠倒了。然后这个祭司回来了，他征服了埃及。他身后有希克索斯人，即亚洲人。他们统治着，然后法老们来了，把他们赶出去，永远地驱逐了他们。
And there's clear kind of garbled trace elements of something about Akhenaten there but it's and and this is why the association is with Freud and the Jews is that it's kind of what what Menethos is doing is he's linking this story with the Jews because the priest who does this Menethos says one of the names that he has is Moses. And so it culminates, you get Tacitus writing in the beginning of the second century AD, who does this, he essentially attributes all this to the Jews. And he says, you know, the Jews, they just turn everything on their heads, whatever most people do, the Jews do the opposite. And so do you think some of this does lie behind sort of historical anti-semitism or or that sort of stuff i i think asmr's case is very convincing i mean i find it very convincing and and i think that the fact that this kind of radical form of monotheism existed, that clearly it was kind of
这里有关于阿肯那顿的一些模糊不清的痕迹，这就是为什么会与弗洛伊德和犹太人产生联系——曼涅托所做的是将这个故事与犹太人联系起来，因为曼涅托说这个祭司拥有的名字之一就是摩西。最终，你会发现塔西陀在公元二世纪初写作时就是这么做的，他基本上把这一切都归咎于犹太人。他说，你知道，犹太人，他们只是把一切都颠倒过来，大多数人做什么，犹太人就做什么相反的事。所以你认为其中一些确实构成了历史上的反犹太主义或诸如此类事情的背景吗？我认为阿斯马尔的观点非常有说服力，我是说我发现它非常具有说服力，并且我认为这种激进的一神教形式的存在，显然被
remembered by the Egyptians as a kind of buried trauma, and that then in the Hellenistic and Roman period it comes to be associated with the Jews, so that the Jews then get associated with this kind of these calumnies that do seem to have inherited, you know, descended down the centuries from the actual time of Akhenaten. I mean, it's impossible to prove, because again, this is kind of the fascination and the frustration of it. But I think it's, I mean, I think it's a really fascinating take on it, really fascinating take. Okay, well, let's, we've got to do some questions, haven't we? Before we do that, I forgot to mention when we came back after the break that we are now doing two podcasts a week and our next podcast is a fantastic podcast about the history of comedy and comedy in history um history as comedy and
埃及人当作一种深埋的创伤所记忆，然后在希腊化和罗马时期，它开始与犹太人联系起来，于是犹太人就与这些自阿肯那顿时代实际流传下来的诬蔑联系在一起。我是说，这不可能被证明，因为这也是这种迷人又令人沮丧的地方。但我认为，我的意思是，这是一个非常迷人的视角，真的非常迷人。好吧，让我们，我们得问几个问题，不是吗？在那之前，我忘了提我们在中场休息回来后，我们现在每周做两个播客，我们的下一个播客是一个关于喜剧历史和历史中的喜剧的精彩播客，嗯，历史作为喜剧，还有
our guest is al murray so don't miss that please now questions graham questions. Graham Elliot, Tom, says, was Tutankhamen really run over by a chariot? I hadn't heard this one, but was he? I thought he had suffered from scoliosis. Well, again, there are all kinds of theories about this. Being run over by a chariot's another. Another was that he was a victim of a murder, kind of smashed on the side of his head.
我们的嘉宾是阿尔·默里，所以请不要错过。现在是提问时间，格拉姆，提问。格拉姆·埃利奥特，汤姆问，图坦卡蒙真的是被战车碾过去的吗？我没听说过这个，但他是吗？我以为他患有脊柱侧弯。好吧，关于这个也有各种各样的理论。被战车碾过是其中之一。另一个说法是他是一场谋杀的受害者，头部侧面遭到重击。
The truth is, I mean, I'm not in any way an expert on this but whenever you look at what people deduce from mummies it seems to change every every decade and the classic example of that is the one that was found in kv55 this mysterious tomb um that was found by theodore davis the american oh yes you were gonna you were gonna listen and huge controversy even about what sex it was was it female was it male at what age was he or she when he died and the consensus now is that it was probably a guy called smenkare brilliant name who may have been tutan karman's half brother may have succeeded uh nefertiti um but again i thought smenkare was a short-lived pharaoh he is he is a short-lived pharaoh, but we know almost nothing about him.
事实是，我是说，我绝不是这方面的专家，但每当你查看人们从木乃伊中推断出什么时，它似乎每十年都在变化，典型的例子就是在KV55中发现的那具木乃伊，那个神秘的陵墓，由美国人西奧多·戴维斯发现的，哦，是的，你正准备听呢，甚至对于它的性别是男是女、他或她在死时的年龄都有巨大的争议，现在的共识是它可能是一个叫斯门卡拉的家伙，一个很棒的名字，可能是图坦卡蒙的同父异母兄弟，可能接替了娜芙蒂蒂，但我也以为斯门卡拉是一个短命的法老，他确实是一个短命的法老，但我们对他的了解几乎为零。
But other people have said that this mummy may be Akhenaten, maybe Nefertiti. And this is the problem, is that we know so little even about the mummies that in a sense you take all the various pieces of this puzzle, of which the vast majority are missing, but you've got just enough pieces to kind of put them together to construct what looks like a kind of plausible picture. But you can never be sure. And the question of how pharaohs die, so how Tutankhamen dies, is a kind of classic example of that. I mean, every decade you will have some new theory that comes up. And the conclusion that I would come to as someone who is in no way qualified to do a kind of cold case
但其他人说这具木乃伊可能是阿肯那顿，可能是娜芙蒂蒂。这就是问题所在，我们对木乃伊了解得如此之少，以至于从某种意义上说，你拿走这个拼图的各种碎片——其中绝大多数都缺失了——但你手里刚好有足够的碎片把它们拼凑起来，构建出一幅看起来很貌似合理的画面。但你永远无法确定。法老如何死去的问题，比如图坦卡蒙如何死去，就是一个典型的例子。我是说，每十年你都会听到一些新理论。而作为一个完全没有资格进行这种冷案尸检的人，我得出的结论
autopsy like this but it would i'm gonna do it anyway i don't think that we'll ever know i don't think we'll ever know right what about this question i mean you mentioned about the gender the the indeterminate gender of some of these bodies and whatnot or the confusion did the egyptians have the same they must have had very different ideas from the ideas that prevailed let's say in the last 2000 years so Nefertiti ruled as a male pharaoh what's all that about again hard hard to be sure and and it's not absolutely definite it's just that this seems to be the kind of the overwhelming weight of evidence. And there does seem to have been a fair degree of gender confusion at Amarna.
像这样，但我无论如何都要说，我认为我们永远不会知道，我认为我们永远不会知道。好吧，那这个问题呢？我是说，你提到了其中一些尸体的性别，不确定的性别或诸如此类的混乱，埃及人是否有相同的观念？他们的观念一定与过去2000年盛行的观念大不相同，所以娜芙蒂蒂曾作为男性法老统治，这到底是怎么回事？同样，很难确定，而且这也不是绝对肯定的，只是这似乎是压倒性的证据分量。阿玛纳似乎确实存在相当程度的性别混乱。
So, you know, there are images of Akhenaten with Nefertiti where it's quite difficult to tell the two of them apart they're both wearing um pharaonic headdresses and both kind of have the contours of a female body um it's quite difficult and and the style of also the style of wig in this period it's kind of a nubian style and men and women again they're very similar and so this all is all part of the fun adding to the complexity is you can't even be sure whether you're talking about men or women to add to your to add to your fun i've basically got your dream question here from mike honcho um he says tom he doesn't even bother addressing it to me he just addressed it to you tom do you subscribe to the idea that akhenaten atonism was an important influence on the theology of christianity and he then says a second
所以，你知道，有些阿肯那顿和娜芙蒂蒂的画像，很难把他们两个区分开来，他们都戴着法老头饰，都有女性身体的轮廓，这相当困难，而且这一时期假发的风格也是一种努比亚风格，男女之间又非常相似。所以这都是乐趣的一部分，增复杂性的是，你甚至无法确定你谈论的是男人还是女人。为了增加乐趣，我这里基本上有迈克·洪乔为你准备的梦想问题，他说，汤姆，他甚至懒得向我提问，他直接问你，汤姆，你是否赞同这样的观点：阿肯那顿的阿顿崇拜是基督教神学的重要影响？然后他提出了第二个
question which i think is actually a very interesting question are the comparable examples you can think of an ancient history of a single individual one individual who so completely transformed their culture so let's do the first bit first christianity do you think it was an influence no i don't think so because nobody knew about it i mean it's you know it's that it is thought that uh psalm 104 is um and contains within it an echo of um of the hymn to the art of the hymn to the art and and perhaps you could imagine that i don't know some syrian subject of pharaoh received it and i i mean again almost impossible to know there is also a very enigmatic um line in acts of the apostles where it suddenly says and moses was learned in all the wisdom of the egyptians
问题，我认为这实际上是一个非常有趣的问题：在古代历史中，你还能想到哪些类似的例子，关于一个单一的个人，一个如此彻底改变了他们文化的个人？所以我们先回答第一部分，基督教，你认为它有影响吗？不，我不这么认为，因为没有人知道它。我是说，人们认为《诗篇》第104篇是，并且其中包含对《阿顿颂诗》的某种回声，或许你可以想象，嗯，法老的某个叙利亚臣民收到了它，我还是那句话，几乎不可能知道。在《使徒行传》中也有一句非常神秘的话，突然说“摩西学了埃及人的一切智慧”，
which is kind of playing into the you know this idea that moses was it was originally an egyptian but i don't think there's anything i mean i don't think christians were aware of this at all and are there other comparable examples you can think of an ancient history of a single individual that so completely, well, attempted to transform their own culture. In the long run, it didn't work. I can't, again, no, I can't think of anyone.
这有点迎合了，你知道，摩西最初是个埃及人的这种想法，但我不认为有什么——我是说，我不认为基督徒对此有什么了解。在古代历史中，你还能想到其他类似的例子吗？关于一个单独的个人如此彻底地——好吧，试图改变他们自己的文化。从长远来看，它没有成功。我还是想不出任何人。
And I think that that's, that's the kind of, it's the unique fascination of this. But that's what makes him seem so modern, isn't it? The new capital, the attempt to completely remake everything i mean that feels yeah see i can't think of that many examples of people doing that before the 20th
我认为这，这是一种，这是它独特的魅力所在。但这不正是让他显得如此现代的原因吗？新的首都，试图彻底重塑一切——我是说，这感觉，是的，所以我回想不起来20世纪之前有多少人做过这种事
century that feels like something you do with 20th century technology and with the kind of 20th century utopianism i mean that's the weird thing that there aren't people doing that in the 12th century or the 15th century they're just continuing in the patterns of their predecessors but akhenaten is doing something unbelievably radical that we now associate with you know the pol pots and the maus and the stalins and so on yeah but but but to pick up on my contest question it is also quite kind of monotheistic in the sense of of um say christianity or i think particularly islam i think the the the kind of islamic anxiety around images the sense that gods that people have been worshiping are in fact idols and have to be overthrown um if if there's a kind of a prefiguring of of christianity in the idea that akhenaten is the son of the of the
这感觉像是你会用20世纪的技术和20世纪那种乌托邦主义去做的事情，我是说奇怪的是，在12世纪或15世纪没有人这样做，他们只是延续着前人的模式，但阿肯那顿正在做一些难以置信的激进事情，我们现在将这些与波尔布特、毛泽东、斯大林等联系起来。是的，但是，顺着迈克·洪乔的问题说下去，它在某种意义上也相当一神教，类似于基督教，或者我认为尤其是伊斯兰教，我认为那种围绕图像的伊斯兰焦虑，那种认为人们一直在崇拜的神实际上是偶像必须被推翻的感觉——如果说阿肯那顿是阿顿之子的观点中存在某种基督教的预示，
artan there is also a kind of definite you know a sense of islam the the way in which muhammad kind of according to to tradition uh purges mecca of of idol worship there is something there and also i tell you what i also detect tom there's a sort of you know they're both desert religions um there's an austerity to atonism if that's the right word yeah yeah uh that that it seems to share with with islam there's a kind of simplicity in um i don't want to say well i mean purity maybe, maybe. There's a sort of a harsh simplicity to Atenism that you can see why it would intoxicate. It would frighten some and intoxicate others.
那也确实存在一种伊斯兰教的意味，穆罕默德根据传统净化麦加偶像崇拜的方式，这其中确实有些相似之处。而且我也告诉你，我还察觉到，汤姆，有一种，你知道，它们都是沙漠宗教，阿顿崇拜有一种苦行僧式的风格，如果这是对的词的话，是的，是的，它似乎与伊斯兰教有某种共同点，有一种简朴的……我不想说……好吧，我是说纯粹性，也许，也许。阿顿崇拜有一种严酷的简朴性，你可以理解为什么它会让人着迷。它会吓倒一些人，也会让另一些人着迷。
Yeah, and I think the harshness is the word. I mean, I think it left very little for people who weren't Pharaoh. And I think that was the problem. Yeah. All right, we've just got time for a couple more questions so lots of questions we had about moses and monotheism which we've kind of done tom slists asks quite a different question what do you think of velikovsky's idea that akhenaten was the inspiration for oedipus oh good question have you are you a fae with you au fait with emmanuel velikovsky i i i actually read him he's bedside reading for me
是的，我认为严酷是恰当的词。我是说，我认为它给除了法老以外的人留下的空间非常小。我想这就是问题所在。好吧，我们刚好有时间再回答几个问题，关于摩西和一神教我们有很多问题，我们已经讨论过了。汤姆·斯利斯特问了一个完全不同的问题：你对维利科夫斯基的观点有何看法，即阿肯那顿是俄狄浦斯的灵感来源？哦，好问题。你熟悉伊曼纽尔·维利科夫斯基吗？我其实读过他的书，他是我的床头书
so velikovsky was um very controversial i think he was an astronomer originally who argued that um venus was in fact a chunk of jupiter that in historical times had had uh kind of migrated and this inspires all the kind of disaster apocalyptic myths that you get and kind of as an extension of that having you know radically uh rewritten astronomy he then rewrites the entire history of of the of the near east as well and argues that the um the conventional uh dating is completely wrong so he identified he said basically he he kind of cuts out a thousand years of history so that um Hatshepsut the 18th dynasty queen is associated with um the queen of Sheba who according to conventional dating had lived centuries and centuries after Hatshepsut so it it's let's say it's not broadly
所以维利科夫斯基非常具有争议，我想他最初是一位天文学家，他认为金星实际上是木星的一块碎片，在历史时期曾发生过某种迁移，这激发了你所得到的各种灾难性末日神话。作为对这一点的一种延伸，在彻底改写了天文学之后，他又改写了整个近东历史，并认为传统的年代测定完全是错误的。所以他基本上切断了一千年的历史，使得第18王朝的女王哈特谢普苏特与示巴女王联系在一起，而根据传统年代测定，示巴女王生活在哈特谢普苏特之后的几个世纪里。所以，可以说它并未被广泛
accepted although there are there are a couple of David Roll is is the kind of example of historians who do make play with this this idea that actually there are there are a couple of david roll is is the kind of example of historians who do make play with this this idea that actually there are centuries that are kind of missing and that if you get rid of them then you can kind of map things up much more much more neatly um but but velikovsky's theory of akhenaten as thompson says is that he was the inspiration for oedipus and um velikovsky identifies Amenhotep III with Laeus, who was Oedipus's father. And he identifies Amenhotep III's wife, Queen Theia, with Jocasta, who is the woman who Oedipus ends up marrying. And there are all kinds of play made with the fact that Oedipus lived in Thebes and Akhenaten lived in Thebes.
接受，尽管有大卫·罗尔这样的历史学家确实利用了这个观点，即实际上有几个世纪是缺失的，如果你把它们去掉，你就可以把事情安排得更整洁得多。但是正如汤姆所说，维利科夫斯基关于阿肯那顿的理论是，他是俄狄浦斯的灵感来源，维利科夫斯基将阿蒙霍特普三世认定为拉伊乌斯，即俄狄浦斯的父亲，并将阿蒙霍特普三世的妻子提亚王后认定为伊俄卡斯塔，即俄狄浦斯最终娶的那个女人。人们还利用俄狄浦斯住在底比斯、阿肯那顿住在底比斯这一事实做了各种文章。
And there are sphinxes in Egypt and there's a sphinx in Oedipus. And it's, you know... It seems a bit desperate. It's kind of fun, but it's nothing more than fun. So what do I think of it? It's a gameplay. It's clearly not true. Well, my wife's just brought me a cup of tea.
埃及有狮身人面像，俄狄浦斯的故事里也有狮身人面像。这，你知道的……这听起来有点绝望。这有点好玩，但也就是好玩而已。所以我觉得它怎么样？这只是一场游戏。显然不是真的。好吧，我妻子刚刚给我端来了一杯茶。
So that feels to me like, unless you really want to answer that question from Michael Ronson... Oh, the beautiful lady has come. Yeah. Who made the big triangle-y things, Michael Ronson said. Aliens or not aliens, Tom? I don't think aliens, no. Ah, disappointing.
所以在我看来，除非你真的想回答迈克·罗森的那个问题……哦，美丽的女士来了。是的。迈克·罗森说，是谁建造了那个大三角东西？是外星人还是不是外星人，汤姆？我不认为有外星人，不。啊，真令人失望。
Well, that's it for today. We've got Al Murray to come on Thursday, who's even more interesting than any of the pharaohs or indeed Tom and me. Thank you for listening. Thanks, Tom. Bye for now. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了，今天的节目就到这里。我们在周四将迎来阿尔·默里，他比任何法老甚至汤姆和我都要有趣得多。谢谢收听。谢谢，汤姆。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取加长单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。